[Musique]
eh bien, aujourd'hui, ce soir, nous
annonçons qu'il y aura désormais une
mise en quarantaine euh pour un certain nombre d'
autres endroits,
y compris euh la France euh la Hollande et
quelques autres
euh c'est parce que nous avons absolument
travaillé si dur
pour nous assurer que  nous gardons nos
chiffres ici et nous ne pouvons pas nous permettre
de réimporter ces cas d'ailleurs et
bien le
gouvernement français a dit que
malheureusement
le virus a mal tourné
là-bas il y a eu une
augmentation de 66% du nombre de euh  des tests positifs
au cours de la dernière semaine seulement et donc
malheureusement la france doit être
ajoutée à la
liste de quarantaine et cela signifie que si
vous revenez de france alors vous devez vous
isoler pendant 14 jours quand vous
revenez de dimanche
bien le le le  les règlements, les lois
changeront
euh euh samedi soir, donc si vous rentrez
à la maison avant, vous
n'avez pas besoin de
vous isoler, mais quand vous
rentrez à la maison, dites à partir du dimanche matin, vous devez vous isoler  e et c'est que j'ai peur
de la loi pendant 14 jours